hi I'm Jordan Fisher and I'm about to
read some some some thirsty tweets
[Music]
Jordan Fischer has way too much sex
appeal to play Evan Hansen Evan Hansen
is not a character that I fantasize
making out with until now
I mean that feels like and I feel like
there there have been some handsome Evan
Hansen's on Broadway so that that kind
of sucks that you feel that way also
Evan isn't supposed to be and is not at
all
and I promise and when you see the show
you will feel the same way but um thank
you though I see what you were doing
there and that means a lot to me I'm
very much appreciated Jordan Fischer
with that half smile on the lip bye nope
nope I wonder what that was I wonder
what daily reminder Jordan Fisher is
daddy AF like someone literally said
yelled daddy to me in a mall once and I
had no clue what to do it that I was
like no Jordan Fisher is so good-looking
and charismatic I can't even it's like
John Ambrose
you shouldn't have to he's a good guy
he's very very likable John Ambrose I
think yeah I don't think you have to
dislike him damn daddy you sexy can I
eat your slick you but this is my hands
are sweating
I love how everyone in the world can
agree that Jordan Fisher has hot AF and
daddy material even the lesbians how
good that was that what actually really
maybe that was a nice one can I say that
one I'm gonna hold on to that one guys
Jordan Fisher singing you're welcome
sounds like sex and I'm pretty sure that
that's not the response I'm supposed to
have sent since Moana huh since its
Moana yeah probably I'm just thinking
about you're welcome sounding like sex I
don't agree but but I flatter do I
appreciate it thank you
Jordan Fisher is both cute and sexy at
the same time and it's really affecting
my sanity I hope you have someone to
speak to I don't intend to damage you by
any stretch of the imagination I
as I promised listen Jordan Fischer is
so cute he can choke me
y'all need y'all need to simmer down a
little bit I think let me just say
Jordan Fischer could literally choke me
what is this and I would thank him for
blessing let me just say yeah I
genuinely think that especially like
current generation social media Zoomers
Millennials alike have all like began to
develop a personality that is literally
just the internet but it's just funny
how they express themselves and then
when I hear it in real life I'm like oh
Jordan Fisher is either a small puppy or
a sex god there is no in-between I have
to say this is actually kind of like
lifting lifting me in a nice way it's
this is really the kind I appreciate
this guy Jordan fish a little is a hell
if I Jordan Fisher his vocals are like
sex to my ears hmm thank you we're
almost to the bottom here guys or our
thirst is almost quenched update Jordan
Fisher owns this whoa I'm getting
married in July guys I'm like I have one
that's nice
Jordan Fisher comes seeing me to sleep
and develop oh man I'm gonna do the hot
if I'm ever suckage okay there's no way
that this one is the very last one in
this thing was this on purpose it's
mesmerizing and really concerning
my mouth is dry and my hands are a
little sweaty so I'm gonna go shower now
I appreciate the love
I'm Jordan Fisher please check out to
all the boys I love before PS I still
love you out on Netflix February 12
hashtag team Jonathan thank you
[Music]